what has life been like for Tina major
Reno since she played the side ponytail
sporting Deb and Napoleon Dynamite
we're taking a look back at her earliest
roles and everything she's been up to in
the years after that indie comedy became
a cult phenomenon a tiny Tina
major Reno first at the scene in 1992
with the short-lived ABC sitcom camp
Wilder part of the famous TGIF lineup
which included hits like full house
Family Matters and Boy Meets World but
not every TGIF show was a hit and there
always seemed to be one show in the
lineup that wasn't up to par with the
other three
unfortunately camp Wilder belonged to
the latter category and the show was
canceled after only 19 episodes camp
Wilder revolved around Ricki Wilder a 28
year old nurse who becomes the sole
guardian of her two teenage siblings
after their parents deaths in addition
to raising her own six-year-old daughter
Sophie who was played by major Rena
their home is turned into a sort of day
care for her siblings and their friends
which comes to be known as camp Wilder
famous faces like Hilary Swank Jerry
O'Connell and Jay Mohr appeared on the
show but it was major Reno's character
who got one of the most progressive
storylines of the series towards the end
of the show's run the six-year-old tells
her family that she wants to be a boy
reflecting progressive transgender
awareness a couple of decades before
virtually any other show who could
forget water roll one of Hollywood's
biggest flops directed by Kevin Reynolds
Waterworld told the story of an earth
after the polar ice caps melting
flooding the planets land surfaces in
creating well of water twirled the movie
starred Kevin Costner is a sort of
evolved fish man who helped save a
kidnapped girl named Enola played by
major Reno who had a mysterious tattoo
on her back that ends up being a map to
dry land
unfortunately the big-budget flick got
middling reviews with Roger Ebert
calling it a picture he's not unhappy to
have seen but can't quite recommend and
it hasn't exactly gone down in history
as a beloved sci-fi action film despite
its cult following by 2004 major Reno
had grown up and out of her childhood
roles but that didn't stop her from
going back to high school at 19 years
old to play Deb in the oft
querque indie comedy Napoleon Dynamite
well anyone else here trying to earn
money for college
your loan goes to college from the
beginning of the movie it felt like
Napoleon and Deb were meant to be but
Napoleon's ego and his eccentric family
kept getting in the way thankfully after
a bit of high school drama a funky
election a lonely prom and a couple of
good deeds Napoleon and Deb found their
way to a romantic game of tetherball the
CW's Veronica Mars was one of those team
shows that developed an adult audience
because it was just that good Kristen
Bell starred as Veronica Mars the
daughter of a disgraced chief of police
who took it upon herself to solve her
best friend's murder
major Reno played Cindy Mac Mackenzie a
computer whiz who had always felt a
little out of place in her family she
utilized veronica services to help
confirm that she was in fact switched at
birth and was actually the biological
daughter of one of the wealthiest
families in Neptune Mac and Veronica's
friendship was a gal-pal match made in
heaven with Mac's tech smarts and
Veronica's sleuthing skills coming in
handy while they tried to solve the
series mini mysteries
major Reno returned his Mac in the 2014
Veronica Mars film and rumor has it
she'll return for Hulu's revival of the
much beloved neo-noir show HBO's big
love followed the story of a polygamist
fundamentalist Mormon family in Utah and
all the drama that accompanied their
lifestyle
major Reno played Heather Tuttle a young
super conservative and devout Mormon who
was best friends with Sarah Hendrickson
the eldest daughter of bill and Barb
played by Amanda ciphered Heather and
Sarah work at a fast food restaurant
together for a short time and Heather
keeps the fact that her father is a
state trooper to herself considering
that what her best friend's family's
doing is pretty much illegal Big Love
actually marks the second TV series in
which major Reno and ciphered acted
together though they never shared any
scenes they both appeared in Veronica
Mars Seyfert played Veronica's best
friend Lilly Kane
whose murder Veronica spent most of the
show's first season trying to solve the
cast of Grey's Anatomy truly feels like
a revolving door sometimes with Ellen
Pompeyo is Meredith Grey holding
everything together majorie knows
Heather Brooks came aboard in season 9
right after a big plane crash finale
that killed off a number of main
characters Brooks was an overly
energetic enthusiastic and bubbly
character who was mostly played for
laughs as a total of knowit's oh girl
hemorrhage sorry I'm interrupting you
guys were having a moment nurse the
intern did have a super sweet side as
well as a temporary romantic dalliance
with another Grey's mainstay dr. Alex
Karev but alas major Reno couldn't
escape Shonda Rhimes acts in grey's
Anatomy's tenth season Brooks was
electrocuted during a storm subsequently
having to undergo brain surgery to clear
a hemorrhage she sadly didn't make it
and the other interns and doctors
realized how much of a joy she truly was
only after she was gone check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]